he says he works out yeah a little bit
it looks like
[Music]
uh who are you hi my name is austin my
name is chloe holders her name is what
chloe holdridge okay well i thought it
was some kind of
d d thing no i thought it was i think it
was some kind of you know what
irish names what's your name megan how
do you spell it
x x z-y-s-x-x like it's not it doesn't
doesn't matter and this is a readout
which is i know there's a reason for
that and people explain it to me but
it's you know the only irish name i know
is flanigan flanagan yeah this other
name irish let me show you know just the
one i know
doesn't sound irish to me o'neil doesn't
sound irish to me
i know too many black dudes from the
states who have that i'm not saying it's
all oh yeah
but like when i hear flanagan olive i
think it's like a leprechaun
before you call me racist it was this
kid by a boy
irish dude named danny boy uh comedian
yeah so because
potatoes because this guy says this
stuff priest could now say it's whiskey
no he's actually irish so it's not
racist are you looking for love
yes i mean i'm single so i am on dating
apps i talk to lots of guys
what do you look for in a partner um
someone that's also open and honest
first i'm gonna say she got some strong
shoulders
hey listen i i'm adding a little
amazonian lady if you
you try to pick a brother up and show
them a good time you know well she's
just
on the table so it looks bigger oh no
then that's a big ass shoulders
i mean
i'm really like an athlete so like i'd
like for her to
have a good physique you're going to be
putting yourself out there by letting
your
date go through your phone before they
meet you what are you going to look for
on their phone obviously
go through like her instagram kind of
see how she is
how she portrays herself his initial
messages to people
is is very telling like is it a hey or
is it a
what are you doing tonight would you
worry about your date seeing on your
phone i didn't really have a chance to
like
delve through my photos at all okay
she's gonna look through your phone
first are you ready to go into the other
room
sure i'm ready to make a fool of myself
there's no way this can go well there's
no way because you just see a bunch of
images screenshots stuff like that out
of context it's going to look strange
if you look through my burner there's a
bunch of screenshots
just the fact that you said burner yeah
i'm calling csi exactly
you know what i'm saying
one of them is their burner it's not a
burner but anyways yeah the fact that i
called it a burner
out of context wrong you haven't gone
through the phone
and right there it sounds wrong probably
the worst thing that someone would see
on my phone if they looked through
me a screenshots of people being creepy
but it's just something that i keep for
backup you know what i mean but out of
context it really looks like i'm saving
those for later
you know i mean too much memes there's
too many memes
in that and phone for a normal person
you know what's something that always
annoys me
is like when girls send those images
that you have to press play on and you
see once
i've screenshotted those before yes to
be like [ __ ] you yeah
yeah no temporary pictures yeah just
about it yeah i don't want anything
incriminating i'm mad at you
do you wanna say hi hi hey he says hey
try not to drop my phone he says try not
to drop my phone
okay we should have put a protector on
it hey if you like it you should put a
ring on it yes you go girl
protect your neck and your phone i'm
just looking at selfies right now
oh he works out he's at a gym or maybe
like a home gym
yeah i have a sweep home gym set up he
says he works out
yeah a little bit it looks like oh my
god
yeah he works out yeah a little bit
because he's not
okay so so so i'm guessing she works out
a lot and so she's kind of disappointed
by his frame
that's what it looks like to me that's
what it looks like to start it's the
whole
pause before he says he works out and
she goes yeah
a little bit she was trying to soften
the blow
saying basically she's physically
disappointed he says he works out
yeah a little bit it looks like
oh man i think he picked up on it um he
has lots of pictures of girls
on here lots of screenshots he has the
weirdest [ __ ] in here like there's a
picture of a girl
on a bike with her ass out austin why
are you taking screenshots of
women with their butts out uh pops up on
my feed
maybe i want to share it with my fellow
brethren
looked a little nervous there austin
definitely look a little nervous
because uh you know um some [ __ ]
lying that's why i'll be
becoming [ __ ] lying because [ __ ]
you know it reminds me of the skit of
dacha bell uh what about the oil
this is like a dating app profile like i
mean i guess if he's sending it to
someone like a friend and saying hey is
this girl cute that would that would be
normal but he likes
has them still like this is from so long
ago dude screenshots everything like
it's just a slight
bit creepy so you think what once we
send the screenshots we go through a
history and delete it
most people who take screenshots just
leave it there forever until you do a
phone cleanup day so for her
this is what i suspect i think she's
unattracted to the dude so she's already
finding reasons
to then there therefore like add on i'm
not in there
no she's but we're supposed to be blind
so she doesn't know she's talking oh
yeah
yeah yeah he works out a little bit a
little i'm telling you i'm wondering if
i've seen him on hinge because i also
have hinge
i want to look at that really quickly
okay so he looks cuter in his hinge
profile than he does like in his
personal
selfies
look at his face he he's uh he's mad
he's big bad he's kicked off he sticks
off
not tick-tock you look you look better
when you try your best
[Laughter]
that's true for everybody ladies uh you
know how you look in your selfies most
of the ones that are on your camera
you don't look that great the ones that
you put online are always your best
photos it's the same thing
oh he's got a fitness video pushing a
sled he's kind of doing it wrong though
we mean he's doing it wrong uh well i'm
a trainer so
boom you can't have shoulders like that
not be a serious athlete
yeah true maybe not the one you post you
know post the best workout video
i mean i've gotten plenty of comments on
him he's hurt
he's hurt ciao
she definitely emasculating him ciao hey
man
if that's how you want to start the
blind date i manage this message that he
sent
may i interest you in some fornication
oh bro
damn right oh my god the girl replied
sounds tasty end of combo
that was a good one
[Music]
hey bro you're having that consolation
prize right now yeah well that was a
good one
she might not like it but it was pretty
[ __ ] good
i feel like he is shorter
than me he looks like he's anywhere from
five seven to five ten maybe five ten
i'm not five seven i'm not five eight
i'm like five nine and a quarter
so yeah approximately five nine point
two three four
five six centimeters i like i said i'm
like five like no
muffin you measured yourself to the t
nobody says five nine and a quarter
yeah and hasn't measured himself 100
true how tall are you
corey i'm 5 10. oh yeah she tower right
over me
i'm five nine and one quarter i'm five
ten yeah she's
i think he's being sarcastic because she
made it such a big deal yeah
did you with about the same height are
you ready for him to go through your
phone
yeah my phone is like mild compared to
that
do you want him to start going through
your phone go for it your battery's low
as [ __ ]
charge your phone okay you being petty
now okay
the hurt is coming out even hey no no no
you know what you know what she was
petty too
so you know i'm not mad at you he said
you're not gonna put me in a youtube
video making me look stupid
no i'm not sipping for nobody i'm going
in he went the
opposite i'm going in i'm going in for
the kill i'm not mad i'm not mad go
ahead
this is a petty ass video this whole
video the vibe of the video
setting these two up knowing that she's
taller and he's short this whole thing
is petty and you know what i love the
most about this
the cut director in the back is just
going
like bird man just this is money right
now it's all in red this [ __ ] about to
die
she does the whole like personalization
thing like what are these called widgets
yeah it's cute it's kind of basic
yeah lady you know what they say let's
go ladies first
petty second
let's just start with instagram athlete
founder of
define beauty brand is that like your
personal business or
uh-huh it is oh neat that's kind of cool
fitness picks
she's feeling herself yep she got yup
yeah she's yolked
i'm bigger than you you know
i work out properly
[Laughter]
that's what happened bro i know these
[ __ ] what's up
no no your technique's off
i'm sorry about that obviously she
thinks she's
she's cute that's for sure all these
different angles and all that dude he
is so judgy you were also super judging
it's just now it's about you
take it like you dash it if i went
through a girl's phone i saw hundreds of
selfies of herself i'd also be like
for you what's creepy for you is just
basic for others
exactly girls do weird stuff like that
with their phone i've seen
when you take the same like every day
click
click yeah you look crazy you look crazy
click you know it's the same angle
same pause same everything the only
thing different is that day
and what you wear creepy like i was nice
to him
basically what she says i could have
shed on you way more yeah oh i see some
ass oof there's a lot of skin going on
here
see these didn't make the ground yeah
what else do you see in her photos
what do you mean what else saw her
[Laughter]
is he wrong though hey man if he looks
creepy you look like a narcissist but
you know
i know you're not it's just most women
just take thousands i just think it's
off-putting personally but hey
do you yeah i agree and some babies
are these yours you got a kid
[Music]
what you got a kid hey you know what
kevin samuels told me like
that's the survivor told me i wish you
tell me this kid is yours this is how he
he sounds exciting he's about to drive
that [ __ ]
let's see let's see let's see yes i have
a son she has a son
you got a whole baby
you got a whole baby or the legs yeah
yeah remember when i was five nine and a
half and you said that was a problem you
got a whole baby
you should be grateful i'm looking at
your picture you got a whole baby who
are you you're you
you got these man's shoulders and you
got a baby no
listen damn how big is his head got them
big shoulders to push him out
all right he's going in
[ __ ] no still live with the parents hey
oh [ __ ]
would you ever date someone who has a
kid uh probably not no
why not
[Music]
you know what this is like you know how
not serious he's taking this like
this is like him saying would you like
some fornication but in real life
yes this is the exact same yes zero
intention of trying to win in this
situation
let me just be pitied and if it happens
it happens yeah but no intentions of
me but yeah i'm a child myself
i'm sure she's fantastic i'm gonna take
him out i don't know
damn a lot of selfies all right so let's
just i'll just go i'll go [ __ ] hinge
let's go
dating app prayer dating app let's do it
i got two likes in the queue
john looking like an idiot liked your
photo
oh [ __ ] i'm messing this dude right now
hey cutie
oh wow yo this [ __ ] going in
hey every dude under 5 foot 10 right now
it's
jumping for joy like go bro go bro
do it for the rest of us bro yeah yeah
yeah and then they look
cursed like they're six foot tall
brother like yo they get the peanut
butter for me
but yo listen i respect it you
plus me tonight does he also have a kid
hey kid for kid there you guys go you
guys can have like
dates to kids
hey man if i had a petty scanner from
dragon ball z that should be over 9 000.
oh yeah
this man is going in he's going in this
man's going in and you know what it's
not
that mad enough you know the date
started off petty he just said
you can do i can do better let me know
he topped it
let me run it i'm gonna get run with it
let's see let's go the thing that
happened is that you set the tone
yep and when nowadays in 2021 when we
say ladies first is we want to see
we want to see the energy yeah and we're
going to meet you with the same energy
you go on
yeah and that's what he's doing yeah and
he's like okay i don't believe in equal
retribution
you know i'm saying if you slap me
scorched earth whatever happens
afterwards happens i don't need to slap
you back
so you know just that's awesome
all right are you ready to meet uh
it's gonna be great it's gonna be
amazing oh yeah
hi hi how you doing all right i guess
you know i have a date later with a guy
with a kid
you know what it's like this is like
when you're at school and you heard
somebody's been talking
about you and you guys are supposed to
see each other at the party and you just
look up you're like
hi nice to meet you yeah hi i heard you
said something
about me no they don't even say that
normally they just stand in front of
each other and trying to act amicably
yeah
i'm the weird dude that said that yeah
what's cracking chloe
you know i was really nice to you it's
really rude
what'd you find on this phone i just a
lot of
screenshots naked women i don't have
naked photos the women were as naked as
you were
chloe in your instagram that's it so
that's it pipe down and what's the issue
with having those images if women are
allowed to be able to put them online
and to broadcast it
why can't you have screenshots of them
no we can't keep them so
we're creepy we're creepy for having
those photos but you're not creepy for
putting them up there nope when you do
it it's like empowerment when we keep
them it's somehow something
shady yeah maybe we just like the photo
that's it what
you think every time a guy has a photo a
sexy photo girl they're out there
beating their meat to it
that's crazy and also i'm gonna say this
you know how many ladies also keep
photos of dudes
who they find supremely attractive but
you don't get it the pictures are there
to be there abba not for you to keep
yeah this is why i say like i think it's
[ __ ] she's calling this creepy i
just think this
she wasn't attractive so she's just
finding reasons but there's nothing
creepy about him keeping photos of girls
the same way there's nothing creepy
about you having photos of yourself
there
or you posting them on the gram you
can't have it both ways you can't post
this everywhere
for everyone to see and then when people
keep it oh this is some shady stuff
what a little bit risque but like you
know
did you even find my risque photos 100
100 you look good without clothes on i
mean yeah i mean that's
that's good now you've seen them so i
just should delete them
so try again you actually look better in
person
your selfie game is a little like 100
means work my photos are
garbage would you two go on a second
date with each other no
not even like a little like a quick
coffee
no no he said no but if she would have
said yes he would have
i feel probably or she would have said
yes and he'd be like
no just to be petty i mean she has no
choice but to say no at this point yeah
i
know i think you're nice i think you're
funny yeah yeah you're just a little
rude
just a lot but definitely not each
other's type and like i have a kid and
that's like an absolute no then then
goodbye
yeah exactly yeah you gotta put out your
intentions and
what you're looking for up front like
obviously don't meet it
so no harm you would have been hilarious
if you looked at her and says
would you like some fornication tonight
that would have been the perfect way to
end that date
that would literally have been the
cherry on top yeah that would have been
perfect
yeah let me listen it's a very awkward
way
to look through someone's messages to
like start off because without con like
i said man whether it's reading
somebody's dms whether it's going
through somebody's phone
when you're just seeing people through
that medium yeah most likely
you're not going to look at them in the
best light you lack the context to
understand any of this stuff
so that's why everything looks way worse
it's like walking upon a crime scene
with no detectives there
and everything's just fresh there's a
dead body there's nothing you don't know
what the hell happened
i'm not at this go ahead not even in a
date setting
looking into someone's phone without any
context
anytime yep it's weird okay
it's gonna you're gonna find something
that you don't want to find because it's
out of context it's possible
anything that you find in a in a phone
can be taken out of its context and it
can be potentially
what if you went through someone's phone
there's literally no photos
that's a burner right even no photos
looks
weird that's a burner you know exactly
it looks suspicious yeah
you go to the border there's no pictures
like okay what you hiding they're gonna
put it to the machine
and scan it if there was some deleted
pictures that's why i never trust people
i don't know facebook profiles
you know everyone curates their profile
to look as good as possible if i
say what's up to anybody and my profile
has no pictures no nothing
i don't have any followers that looks
weird even when it's clean it is it
looks weird something can look weird
you know what i mean so yeah yeah
because our our minds inherently go to
the worst possibility
because of the fact that we're just
primed for that that's it
so we see anything like creepy oh this
or that and just like man
it's normally never as bad as we make it
out to be you know that's my thoughts on
that
as far as him being petting them being
petty i mean listen
i don't endorse it but it makes for a
great youtube video so i'm not gonna
complain
that's what i thought about it was it
yeah somebody said
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below would you have handled it
the same or would you have done it
differently
also we have bonus videos extra footage
that you can find only on patreon so be
sure to subscribe
and if you guys are enjoying today's
video having a good laugh subscribe
comment like it helps us out with the
algorithm let's go all right let's make
the brand even stronger
[Music]
foreign